(Intense music)
Brother Day:
This is an age of darkness.
(Intense music)
Gaal Dornick:
I have dreams sometimes, about
things that will happen.
Gaal:
And I wake up terrified.
(Beasts roaring)
(Intense music)
Gaal:
Despair, death, destruction.
(Intense music)
Gaal:
This is even bigger than the
last crisis.
(Intense music)
Brother Day:
An empire breathes respect. It
requires it for it's life.
The Foundation is a
threat to me.
(Intense music)
Brother Day:
I will look at them in the eye,
and reclaim what is ours.
(Intense music)
For all of us to survive, we
have to face them.
We need to be in the fight.
(Thunder rumbles)
(Engines rumble)
(Intense music)
Hari Seldon:
We fight for Peace.
Show yourself!
(Intense music)
Hari:
Not because we fear we will
lose...
(Intense music)
Hari:
...but because we know...
(Intense music)
Hari:
...that if there is war...
Seldon!
(Intense music)
...we will win.
(Beast roars)
(Day screaming)
(Intense music)
We are taking the planet!
It's time you and I had a
reckoning.
(Music)